on en vient maintenant à cette
information qu'il faut encore vous
donner au conditionnel puisqu'elle n'a
pas reçu ce soir de confirmation
officielle Nicolas et Cécilia Sarkozi
auraient engagé une procédure pour
officialiser leur séparation interrogé
sur le sujet l'Élysée elle n'a souhaité
faire aucun commentaire l'absence de
Cécilia Sarkozi au côté de son époux
depuis plusieurs semaines avait bien sûr
fait naître des doutes ce serait en tout
cas une première sous la 5e République
Véronique Saint-Olive syvain d'ba depuis
des semaines les journaux alimentent la
rumeur d'une séparation des époux
Sarkozi en effet la dernière apparition
publique de Cécilia Sarkozi remonte au
14 juillet dernier sur le Peron de
l'Élysée absente de toutes les
cérémonies officielles elle est absente
aussi en Bulgarie lorsque le président
Siran 2 mois après la libération des
infirmières pourtant chaque fois qu'il
est interrogé le porte-parole de
l'Élysée oppose la même
réponse je n'ai aucun commentaire à
faire sur cette question mais ce matin
sur son site Le Nouvel Observateur va
plus loin il affirme que la séparation
serait consommée comment est-ce que vous
avez eu cette information écoutez nous
avons eu cette information lundi soir
par un
informateur qui était
manifestement avec le couple ou avec
Madame
Sarkozi ou en tout cas en ligne directe
avec elle et pratiquement je dirais en
temps réel c'est vrai que cette source
est proche de Madame
Sarkozi et c'est vrai que donc ça
semblerait indiquer que c'est elle qui
souhaitait que cette information soit
rendue publique la vie politique
continue mais dans les couloirs de
l'Assemblée on ne parle que de cela il
apparaît que le Président de la
République connaît aujourd'hui une
épreuve affective aussi sans doute une
épreuve politique parce qu'il a gravi
les échelons du pouvoir avec son épouse
son ex-épouse le seul qui a commenté sa
vie privée ce soit lui-même Nicolas
Sarkozi lui enchaîne sa journée comme si
de rien n'était rendez-vous avec le
président irien puis avec le président
grec cet après-midi discours au Conseil
économique et social sur la lutte contre
la pauvreté mais les questions sur sa
situation personnelle sont plus que
jamais
malvenu